it's been a year
it's finally been a year since I moved
to Japan so much has happened I thought
it's time for
guess it
I want you to guess it say it out loud
why
[Music]
you guys just can't get anything right
first off I met Mr B's hooray all right
you guys see the comments where are they
let's see how long we have to scroll
[Music]
ah
Jimmy's a freaking giant why is everyone
so tall God damn it so we were
on this sloped Hill and I was I joked to
him I was like hey you should stand at
the bottom of the hill and Timmy's so
nice he was like oh you want me to do
that I'm like no I'll
I'll be a total if I make you do
that
that was a fun and strange day I don't
know if the video is up yet but it
should be very fun I've never been so
scared in my entire life and I thought I
didn't was able to be that scared we
rode one of those roller coasters and
you've seen those clip where people
going like ah and then they pass out
and they didn't remember anything I feel
like that happened to me I don't know
you're beginning to look more like your
father dude I've always looked like my
dad especially if I wear the glasses and
it was so much fun we took a photo
together let's see
there you go my the old pops looking
good for 65. got good jeans oh okay here
we go oh good
found the original photo turns on two
sisters being humble about it this looks
more like it
thank you
this is how I feel
people can get hair transplants why
can't I just be tall
the meme That Never Dies
our auditoring at PewDiePie chairs
that's Frank right on blank looking good
we'll break your back but it's worth it
wrong you didn't guess today's sponsor
but you didn't ask
BOGO sale buy one get one
that means if you
buy one get one it's not that
complicated we have these sexy mmm so
good looking anime inspired PewDiePie G
fuels grease skin baby
looking nice
makes me feel strong do you feel as you
know it's the greatest drink of all time
especially the PewDiePie flavor you get
someone right congratulations and for
those of you dumb dumbs who don't know G
fuel is an energy drink with zero sugar
only 15 calories
140 milligrams of caffeine
makes you laser focused
with vitamins and antioxidants helps
immunity with plant-based ingredients
all in all making g-fuel the goal I love
G fuel give it a try because now
good you buy one you get one
congratulations
and to celebrate my anime Reese skin you
can Bogle some of the greatest anime
related flavors that there is Naruto
Sage Mode I love this one it's white
peach peach is such a good flavor I
highly recommend checking that one out
we have the Dragon Ball Kamehameha I
never watched Dragon Ball
please still buy the G fuel I know
Dragon Ball Z hidden hidden power
where is it
blue eyes anime and also throwing Dead
Space Plasma energies which is
strawberry candy in there that's what's
fun about G fuel getting different
flavors getting different fun I actually
thought about this too in Japan you have
to rinse the bottles of drinks when
you're done with them wait for them to
dry then smush them then remember to
recycle them on the day of the recycling
thing and you know all these people that
carry around their uh their water
bottles everywhere like I'm drinking
water I'm still a saving Planet G fuel
drinkers be like bruh I'm already I've
been doing it forever you feel it's not
just for gaming it's for just making
your day a little better day is always
better with a drink on your side that's
my philosophy in life thank you G4 for
sponsoring this video and making me able
to provide the best drink of all time
the PewDiePie G feel Flavor now in anime
skin check it out well it was nice while
it lasted PewDiePie got bang it's really
cool because twitch doesn't just like
YouTube doesn't say what made you bam so
I don't know probably shouldn't have
been streaming the videos from 2017 but
hey
it was a weird time everyone thought I
was hacked first because I we're doing a
24 7 live stream on Twitch just for fun
I thought it could be a good way to make
people as well like have the chat and
watch videos together and it's there if
people want it because I have so many
goddamn videos right no one knows I
don't care it's back up
everyone to check out his lamp
hey I'm working on a 3D print video and
I've been messing around just like doing
stuff in public I removed them
afterwards but that this is one of the
things it'll come up when I'm ready I
don't know it's been really fun actually
no
stop it now I have to fix it
oh hey I just gotta take over no it's so
good what I asked for strong long legs
what the is that all right I'll
take those
calves just like I had never too old to
be a bro well it looks like he's Putin's
bodyguard or some what is happening
here sorry sir PewDiePie just uploaded
I'll be right back all right so people
are saying they're 41 is still watching
hell yeah I'm 51 but I'm really 19.
that's how it goes I found mine all day
in a list of karaoke song in the
Philippines God damn it
we did karaoke when my parents were here
and my mom kept going where's shazanya
why don't they have it
headaches like that but maybe nice
during our wedding when the we played
lasagna on the on the Dance Floor she
sang the loudest she's so funny why what
language would PewDiePie's kids speak
English Swedish Italian Japanese
I'm told that kids can learn many many
languages as long as like if I spoke
Swedish Mike just speaks Italian maybe
together English and then in public
Japanese
it will be a confused child regardless
apologize in advance
for having a baby we're no longer Bros
we're gonna be uncles what's up my
uncles Uncle fist
that's sweet man let me live to the
fullest hell yeah
oh
I was like wait a minute is did the
shutter go off because we had an
automatic timer on it and I was like
good photo Good Times feelings please do
a toilet review all new iPhone users
making fun of people tweeting from
Androids which you could be on my effing
level Gucci smart toilet is that an
actual thing no no it's not
disappear
is that
what is that
RGB toilet RGB toilet gamer toilet hell
yeah gamer toilet that's gonna be the
next uh PewDiePie chair version
absolutely
[Music]
spell it at the cheap price of 99.99
cringe weeaboo based epic Japanese
enjoyer
looking good Jack this is beautiful I
want to ask I've done it too and I look
way more cute don't even try Jack my
stomach grumbled while I had a Swedish
friend's house and they took me out the
backyard and broke both my kneecaps good
as they should is this meme still going
on about Swedish people not offering
food because it's just facts okay stop
asking us for food is weird we will
break your knees
thank you
how do you accidentally buy a car oh
I just I fell I literally just fell and
then I had the keys to the car in my
hand
that's so good I accidentally got two
cards I might have to show you rest in
peace to the Toyota and getting more
family car now to be honest so if you
guys have any suggestions let me know is
it too early to worry for Pete's Channel
email Benny Quinn my daughter doesn't
want it freaks her out I want to get
back my money best offer I'll give you a
hundred dollars to tell her it's sold
hide it in the attic for two weeks take
it out and put it back in the room while
she's sleeping
[Music]
can't wait to be in the head
I stand by this if you're not
traumatizing your children for your own
entertainment then what's the point ah
what do you think I'm having a game
uh devil Bring It On responding to my
latest video thanks for playing the
gaming Celebration the game is not 50
off
that's so cool I really enjoy that game
I've been playing it on my own now too
check out my video it's epic is that
Austin Bradley hell yeah I wanted two
person say congratulations to Felix and
Martin welcome to the 3D printing dance
club
hey I love it Joey revealed that the
babies are fish long before the latest
video but the good stuff is sure sure
the first thing you're gonna do to when
you see your newborn son is you're gonna
show them this video and be like he said
it oh
to me if you like the omariable I'm
smacking it out of here he said it no
way yeah it's a boy we're having a boy
in case we didn't know I think it might
be time to tell you guys the gender
yeah
[Laughter]
so there's a coin nobody which
represents children's day but originally
I think they were for uh the boys day
it's a boy having a boy and I'm so
excited maybe he is 180 yes
I am
where is it
I'm tired of it
all right what does that what does that
say
I also look like a drug dealer on my
passport I don't know why 180.
don't ever doubt me
and you know what I've been doing these
stretching exercises I bet you I'm even
taller than that I bet you I'm huge
destroyed lonely is a 19 year old no way
um I don't really why I'm not into the
streaming World I'll be seeing it so
much but I don't really care for no
streamer but YouTuber
I like PewDiePie I also videos yeah
co-hosts seem to moderately agree uh I
don't know who this is destroy lonely
looked like he was high off his balls
man jeez
I wanted to I won I really wanted to
like it
I'm sorry
but thank you
not bad not bad all right let's go over
there I've seen a few bullet Clips in
the last couple of Vlogs we'll ever make
a video about it uh yeah I think I'll do
one after I've been doing it for a
little longer because I'm really
enjoying it my hands are signed paper
wait if I ever touch my see how she just
cringes because it's like
it's the worst it's really fun I
recommend it's it's like a video game
exercise right they have all these
levels and different colors and and
then you want to level up to the next
one I don't know it's fun although surf
season is back and I'm very excited did
I blatantly rip up Felix wedding outfit
yes am I proud of myself yes looking
fine sir well then
curse your abbreviated sub count now I
can't tell if he's losing or gaining
subscribers waiting for PewDiePie to hit
112 million subscribers I am growing I
think with like the smallest
subscribe
i112 please
what do I have to do huh what I gotta do
sex tape with markiplier I'll do it sex
playing table Markiplier at 112 million
subscribers you've heard it here first
Mark said yes
thank you for watching this video hope
you enjoyed it's been fun to check in
with you guys hope you're doing well
I'm not gonna promise a bunch of other
videos but I have been working on other
videos and they're coming so see you
soon hey hey bye bye all right next up
we're gonna try out chat GPT make a
sponsor call ad for nordvpn in PewDiePie
style start the video by roasting your
audience for not guessing that's
that's way too long
ladies and gentlemen today's sponsor is
no one
that's right nobody saw this one coming
you all thought you had it figured out
but surprise sometimes life throws you
what the
all right let's kick off this Wildlife
together no sponsor no problems
yeah
he's a gentlemen today's sponsor is no
other than nordvpn that's right I
apologize for the previous confused but
I'm here to talk about the incredible
benefits of nordvpn if you don't use
nordvpn then you're a dummy damn here's
for example me watching anime without
nordvpn wow so many options but with one
click of a button I'm fastly connected
and boom I mean baby nordvpn lets you
quickly and safely transform your
experience online there's absolutely no
reason why you shouldn't have a VPN
unless you want to know if you're online
Internet experience of course dummy and
I know you're dumb because you couldn't
guess today's sponsor after all the hits
nor VPN should really be called more VPN
because unlike other vpns they have ton
of amazing features and they just keep
adding more and more to keep you safe
online I'm sure you or maybe you know
someone that has been hacked online but
nordvpn has you covered with web
protection protection from malware and
trackers file protection you down oops
clicked on band file I know you click on
band files
don't look at me like
[Music]
it's an amazing feature I use it every
single day and I highly recommend you
sign up and if you use my link
nordvpn.com PewDiePie you get the best
offer available for nordvpn so make sure
to sign up with the link in the
description support the channel protect
yourself online and unlock full
potential of internet thank you nordvpn
for sponsoring this video I didn't even
need an AI for that bit